of course
no
morir no me asusta
porque realmente creo que la muerte no
es el final'
y si dios dice que mi camino se estará
acá o ir a luchar
entonces iré a lucharlo
en true faith lex fighting
[Música]
yang grids el diseñador de moda
ucraniano había sido anunciado como la
cita ineludible de la semana de la moda
de berlín pero no pudo salir de kiev así
que no dudó impedirles ayudar a los
miembros del movimiento activista
fashion revolution utilizando sus
diseños los voluntarios recrearon una
colección en los talleres de berlín e
inmediatamente dije que sí porque sé que
esto es lo que queremos hacer con
fashion revolution y necesitamos ayudar
y nuestra red es tan fuerte que es
posible hacerlo
para ser revolución es un gran
movimiento de activismo del amor
probablemente el más grande del mundo
estamos presentes en más de 94 países
nacimos a raíz de la catástrofe de la
rana plaza en 2013 que fue el mayor
desastre industrial de la moda en el
mundo murieron mil 138 personas al
derrumbarse un edificio en daca
bangladesh y este pasión open estudio
que es una de las iniciativas de fashion
revolución es realmente lo que
intentamos hacer darles voz darles un
lugar darles el honor que merecen y el
apoyo que necesitan
no obstante jiang greetfeld pudo
participar a través de una aplicación de
videoconferencia
la idea principal de la colección no era
mostrar las prendas ni las tendencias
sino mostrar una de las cosas más
importantes que usaremos en la próxima
temporada las prendas no nos protegerán
si no que nos protegerán los
sentimientos y las sensaciones
sentimientos como la bondad el amor la
independencia
en berlín mucha gente ayuda y mucha
gente llama mucha gente expresa que les
importa lo que está pasando
y es lo más valioso decidí que nuestra
misión es la moda y tenemos que hacerla
al 100%
y tal vez sea algo horrible de decir
pero tal vez esta guerra nos ha ayudado
a despertar y entender de inmediato lo
que está sucediendo
y por qué estamos aquí y cuál es nuestra
misión en este planeta
no estamos aquí solo para comer ya
dormir y pasar los fines de semana
con nuestros amigos bebiendo alcohol
sam's todos los diseñadores de moda
invitados a esta semana de la moda de
berlín se preguntaron participar o no en
esta edición dada la situación en
ucrania
es una decisión muy difícil y sé que
parece una estupidez pensar en un
desfile de moda en esta época porque
porque necesitamos la moda ahora
pero creo que el arte y la creatividad
son un impulso muy importante
y siempre han hecho parte de la paz
porque calman la mente si todos fuéramos
artistas en este mundo no habría guerras
creo que es importante que los artistas
no dejen de crear aunque hay un momento
muy difícil
espero que todo el mundo lo entienda y
espero encontrar las palabras adecuadas
porque es muy difícil encontrar las
palabras adecuadas
otros diseñadores optaron por quedarse
en casa o mejor en sus talleres
natacha font hirschhausen es una de las
primeras defensoras de la moda y
corresponsable su mantra es cero
residuos
y reducimos la energía utilizada en 50
mega julios
ahorramos 14 años de agua potable para
un adulto con solo un traje y reducimos
las emisiones de co2 en un 60% en
comparación con un traje convencional
y para reducir aún más los residuos
la mayoría de nuestras prendas se
fabrican por encargo no hay exceso de
producción porque un gran problema en la
industria de la moda es también el
exceso de producción
por ejemplo las grandes empresas solían
quemar su stock muerto
o sea las prendas que no se pueden
vender ni siquiera en las rebajas eso es
un gran problema y tenemos que
combatirlo lo combato mediante el diseño
por encargo sólo se producen las prendas
que se venden y todo es hecho aquí no no
todo también tenemos un centro de
producción pero también en berlín en
cuanto a la colección de joyas fue
realizada por calista designs en la
india la empresa apoya principalmente a
las mujeres de las zonas rurales lo cual
es muy importante y realmente importante
para mí es un mensaje político la moda
debe ser política debe ser lo punto
final
palabras sencillas para expresar una
verdad que difícilmente puede ponerse en
duda
[Música]